bonsoir à tous mon nom c'est marca et as
romero je suis directrice du laboratoire
d'innovation et numérique pour
l'éducation line qui est un nouveau
laboratoire à l'université nice sophia
antipolis comme vous avez pu l'entendre
mon accent il est pas niçois mon accent
il aidé barcelone mon passeport et les
français et ma fille et les canadiennes
mais comme chercheur et comme
enseignante sans frontières la question
que je me pose c'est la question des
usages du numérique à l'école
faut-il intégrer le numérique à l'école
oui ou non ok on a déjà des ouïes
excellent c'est super parce que après on
va voir si vous dites oui où
ça dépend ok donc on commence et je
voudrais savoir combien d'entre vous ont
des enfants de moins de 10 ans ok donc
maintenant avec ou sans enfant je vais
vous proposer d'imaginer que vous avez
dix ans et encore tous vos cheveux et
que vous regardez à cette image
ok qu'est ce que vous voyez
ok il y en a qui ont vu que moi il y en
a des vieux que moi qui ont vu un
téléphone à cadran mais si vous montrer
sa des enfants il ne voit plus un
téléphone il voit une tomate avec des
lunettes de soleil qui sont plus à la
mode
ok donc vraiment ça a beaucoup changé en
réalité cette thématique
c'était un personnage super cool et
super branché des années 90 et on
continue dans les dents les images qui
nous font sentir vieux donc moi j'ai
appris à la biographie donc avec ce type
de machine nous aussi on ne se trompe et
nos doigts été arrachés entre les deux
touches
j'ai connu aussi les cassettes et
l'utilisation des stylos bic pour les
enrouler les déroulée et les walkman
tout ça pour nos enfants ce sont des
technologies qui la font les mêmes
effets que moi ça me fait à la voir ces
deux types et ça existe et ça c'est
horrible
donc nous avons vraiment connu un
progrès technologique qui a été très bon
mais qui nous a fait parfois tomber dans
une certaine technophilie je vous
rassure la technophilie n'est pas une
maladie c'est pas contagieux a priori
mais c'est un enthousiasme trop
important pour les soi-disant nouvelles
technologies donc il ya quelques années
en arrière et en étant technophiles donc
je travaillais dans des start up en
e-learning c'était l'époque où on
pouvait se faire embaucher à deux très
rapidement au bout d un entretien en 25
minutes est aussi c'était l'époque où
encore comme aujourd'hui on court à la
nouveauté technologies c'était donc
comme un hamster qui courent à
l'intérieur d'une roue et qu'il faut
courir très vite parce qu'il faut
toujours se tenir à jour des nouveautés
technologiques mais je veux q3 crise
existentielle fortes qui ont fait que
les hamsters technophiles à moi a sorti
de la route ou plutôt il a été éjecté
donc j'ai mordu la poussière et j'ai il
est temps de réfléchir première crise
existentielle j'ai connu l'obsolescence
donc j'étais développés dans un langage
de programmation que peut être certains
d'entre vous connaissent
l'action script etc de langage là des
jours au lendemain quelqu'un en
californie a décidé que il ne voulait
plus de flash dans ses pommes et du jour
au lendemain nous les développeurs
action script sommes devenus obsolètes
yep deuxième crise existentielle donc je
me suis dit bon bah se lancer on a créé
une entreprise et a maintenant parce que
c'est pas trop simple de créer une
entreprise je veux me lancer dans une
thèse en e-learning à l'époque j'étais
nolife j'avais pas d'enfant donc je
pouvais encore travailler la nuit et
voilà des sphères une thèse ça a été
toute une démarche qui est qui a changé
ma manière de penser
d'un côté mon mari a pris ma place en
cuisine mais je puis aiguisé la pensée
critique
la démarche scientifique nous apprend à
nous poser de vraies questions et donc
la question d'heures
quels sont les effets du numérique en
éducation et pour l'apprentissage est ce
que ce sont des effets positifs et tout
de suite on va répondre oui les
numériques à l'école si oui où est ce
qu'il ya des effets négatifs et les
réponses malheureusement c'est pour ça
qu'un recherche on se pose beaucoup de
questions et on n'a pas de choix de
réponse c'est que les réponses ne sont
pas toujours très claires et face à ça
je voudrais que ça ça reste la meilleure
technologie donc enfin en cas de doute
vaut mieux privilégier les papiers
crayons
par exemple nous savons aujourd'hui que
quand on prend des notes sur papier
crayon peut-être il y en a qui prennent
encore des notes dans des blocs notes
ouais ok ça va donc vous pouvez vous
rassurer vous n'êtes pas has been
préhistorique vous avez vous êtes
simplement en train d'utiliser la
meilleure technologie pour mémoriser les
informations parce que quand on compare
la prise de notes avec papiers crayons
et on la compare avec la prise de notes
ces ordinateurs ce n'est pas du tout les
mêmes résultats au memories beaucoup
mieux la prise de notes qu'on fait au
crayon et ça ça pourrait être à la liste
de tout un ensemble de jason pourrait
passer la nuit à décrire plan des
résultats qui vont dans ce sens là donc
on peu plus pour ne pourra plus répondre
oui
lesnumeriques à sa place à l'école il va
falloir que les numériques fasse ses
preuves pour un trade à l'est
l'homme mais les crises existentielles
ne sont pas finis il y en a une
troisième est sûrement il y en aura plus
d'autres à l'avenir
ça a été de devenir maman et là d'un
coup en fait tous ces mini jeu que j'ai
développé auparavant qu'avec flash comme
ça existait encore tous ces technologies
donc que j'étais coupable des
contribuables à collaborer d'un coup je
ne voulais plus pour ma fille parce que
nous voulons touch lé meilleur pour nos
enfants
et justement c'est peut-être pas les
meilleurs qu'on peut offrir à nos
enfants
je vois trop souvent des enfants a dit
aux écrans parfois ils ont à peine huit
mois qu'ils se tiennent entre leurs
mains leurs petites mains des téléphones
des tablettes et toutes sortes de
technologies
c'est sûr qu'en tant que parents nous ne
voulons faire une soirée tranquille au
restaurant qu'est ce que nous allons
faire nous sortons les mobiles et nous
débrancher nos enfants ok mais en
faisant ça nous interféron des manières
très graves sur les programmes naturel
d'apprentissage des enfants 1
la découverte de leur environnement et
we can il se met sous la table des
clients à côté d'eux les interactions
avec d'autres humains quand ils nous
interrompre tous les deux minutes pour
nous expliquer un v10 donc oui les
craintes ça nous facilite la vie c'est
confortable pour les parents mais ils
aiment perfer dé manière trop importante
sur les apprentissages des enfants dans
ce contexte les cols et parfois les
seuls endroits où les enfants peuvent
encore apprendre et jouer sans écran et
parce que c'est comme ça je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'on applique un principe de
précaution
c'est à dire qu'elle si on n'est pas
certain de la plus value et de la
pertinence des usages du numérique à
l'école
il faudrait plutôt s'assurer qu'on ne
sait encore utiliser un crayon pour
écrire
les chercheurs entre et tricot à l'espé
de toulouse nous rappelle que ya eu
beaucoup des mythes avec les
technologies nous avons associé la
technologie en disant voilà les
numériques motiver les élèves c'est
toujours une innovation mais ça ça a été
une autre à hamster technophiles qui
nous a fait dire ça nous y sommes
vraiment enthousiastes avec tous ces
deux nouveautés technologiques et nous
avons cru qu'elle est numérique
harley résoudre tous les problèmes à
l'éducation la personnalisation
l'adaptation scolaire la motivation
parce que les activités sont nuls
tout allait très résolus avec les
numériques même la gestion de classe et
mais c'est incroyable on a cru que les
numériques était magique
et pourtant les dernières études
internationales de l ocde nous montre
bien le contraire plus les enfants
passent du temps en classe face à un
ordinateur
- les résultats sont bons en
mathématiques cela devrait nous faire
réfléchir
mais je vais vous donner de l'espoir
dans cette deuxième partie parce que
quand le cde appelle les différentes
pays
huambo en fac je sais pas combien ce
travail il leur demande les airs du
numérique à l'école et chaque pays
donc il va renvoyer un numéro je sais
pas comme ils l'obtiennent réellement
mes cd quantitatif le c d e ne
s'intéresse pas à la qualité pédagogique
des usages du numérique à l'école
et là il faut vraiment faire la
différence parce que ce n'est pas la
même chose garder clic clic série mini
jeux dans lesquels il va y avoir jusqu'à
identifier une réponse qui est fausse il
ne répondait ce qui est vrai des usages
comme la robotique pédagogique dans
lesquels les élèves vont être engagés
dans une démarche de co création dans
lesquelles il va y avoir des design de
la modélisation de l'ingénierie et de la
résolution de problèmes complexes
bref il faut vraiment faire la
différence entre à la quantité et la
qualité pour prendre l'exemple de la
nourriture ce n'est pas la même chose 5
g des frites belges ou de patatas bravas
ce que 5 g domenech bio aux épinards
donc il faut vraiment que on dépasse la
question de la quantité des numériques à
l'école pour se poser la question
la qualité des usages du numérique à
l'école
pour cela nous avons travaillé adapter
un schéma de les bacs et en faire cinq
niveaux d'usagés numériques à l'école
dans un extrême pour simplifier on à la
consommation passive
on est juste devant un écran et on va
regarder des choses dans notre extrême
au nez dans les usages participatif du
numérique
mais prenons un exemple tout d'abord je
vais vous questionner comme canon et en
classe et je vais vous demander combien
d'entre vous se rappellent la différence
entre une roue motrice et une roue
réceptrice dans un engrenage
ok c'est assez catastrophique donc à
cela veut dire que soit l'école n'a pas
été si bonne soit vous n'étiez pas assez
bon soit les deux en même temps ok donc
ça veut dire que voilà les laissons sur
les machines simples donc les engrenages
ne vous est pas resté sûrement vous
n'avez pas manipuler des engrenages à
l'école prenons l'exemple de ces cinq
usages du numérique
tout d'abord la consommation passive à
cet usage c'est les moins celui qui
engage les moins les élèves dans une
démarche créative
là il s'agit juste d'accéder à une
ressources numériques éducatives
ça sent bien mais au fait en réalité
c'est juste lire un texte certains
manuels et scolaires numériser ou
regarder encore une vidéo sur les
engrenages d'un vélo moi personnellement
je préfère sortir les élèves des classes
et leur faire jouer avec des engrenages
d'ambré vélo mais revenons au numérique
consommation interactive dans cette
deuxième usage
on est en train de dépasser juste le
fait de regarder et on peut cliquer
c'est déjà une avancée on peut cliquer
et on peut sélectionner la bonne ou la
mauvaise réponse
là par exemple à l'écran vous voyez une
question comment s'appelle l'art où que
l'on tourne en premier étant donné que
vous n'étiez pas à identifier les bons
usages en fait vous ne vous le rappeliez
pas qu'est ce que c'était une roue
motrice et une roue réceptrice il est
possible et bhl est possible que vous
répondiez alazard et là on a cinquante
pour cent des chances quand même de
réussir
donc ce qui nous arrive avec ce type de
contenu c'est que parfois les résultats
sont meilleurs mais ce n'est pas parce
que les élèves connaissent mieux c'est
parce qu'il ya 50% des possibilités de
réussir bon si vous pouvez vous prenez
plus des réponses y en a moins mais il
ya laser qui intervient là dedans
passons maintenant aux usages qui en
gach l'élève dans la création de contenu
tout d'abord au troisième niveau on à la
création des contenus individuel on peut
par exemple créer une affiche créer une
animation prendre ses lego créé des
engrenages faire soi même avec les
élèves une vidéo
ou encore faire une programmation
certains programmes comme et scratch
avec ou sans robot pédagogique à la
sortie ce sont d'autres types d' usage
dans lesquels l'élève n'est pas juste à
consommer des contenus déjà tout fait
mais il est à construire 10 contenu avec
les numériques
mais encore mieux qu'à naissance à un
équipe c'est sûr que pour nous
enseignants tu sais plus bruyant mais
pour eux c'est mieux parce que
travailler en équipe ça veut dire s'est
disputé ces disputes et ça veut dire qu
on confronte parfois des idées et que ça
peut donner parfois à des conflits sous
ce collectif c'est à dire que l'idée
erronée qu'on a au départ elle est
confrontée à celle des autres mais alors
encore plus loin les points ici c'est de
faire des usages du numérique dans
lesquelles les numériques n'est pas
l'élément important c'est juste un outil
des peluches dans un projet qui engage
l'élève dans un projet collectif et
participatif comme par exemple la
création des maquettes des villes
dans ces cas là les ingrédients ne sont
pas l'objectif central
on a rajouté d'autres objectifs il faut
créer une maquette des villes donc il
faut construire des objets physiques
mais il faut aussi créer des véhicules
autonomes
il faut créer des grilles intelligentes
il faut créer des ascenseurs donc il
faut vraiment comprendre qu est ce qu un
agrainage les manipuler elle est
programmée pour qu'il fonctionne
réellement
on est en train de relever les niveaux
et l'exigence tout en introduisant pas
simplement des connaissances mais
également des compétences là pour
conclure on est donc face à 5 paysage du
numérique et je vous pose la question
selon vous à l'école quels sont les
usages les plus habituelles si vous
pensez que c'est l'uzège des
consommation passive donc vous lever un
doigt
si c'est la consommation interactive
dans les fêtes déclic et bref on voulait
lever deux doigts si c'est la création
de contenu individuel 3 doit co création
de contenu quatre doigts et si vous
pensez que c'est l'usagé
cinq étoiles donc co création
participative de contenu donc vous
l'avez 5 doit donc selon vous quels sont
les usages du numérique à l'école
ok donc je vois énormément
ok il y en a un doigt deux doigts de
dois énormément de deux doigts et vous
avez gagné
ok excellent donc en fait l'usagé qu'on
a constatée dans lé cadre des projets qu
créatique c'est surtout des usages des
consommations interactive les suivant et
c'était pas si mauvais donc que c'était
la création de contenu individuelle mais
on retrouve presque pas des projets qui
se situe dans la crau création
participative dans ces mêmes projets par
contre on a mené des ateliers dans
lesquels les élèves étaient dans cette
niveau là et beaucoup d'enseignants nous
disait annoncé ça va trop loin ça va
trop loin par rapport au programme
justement les élèves ont réussi et se
sont engagés énormément parce que
c'était bien plus difficile est bien
plus complexe que ce qu'on leur propose
habituellement en classe pour finaliser
donc la question il ne s'agit pas je
vous ai posé une mauvaise question au
départ qui était celle des numériques ou
pas à l'école donc elle répondre ce
n'est pas simple n'est pas binaire oui
ou non la question est les serres la
qualité des usages du numérique à
l'école
il faut que nous allions au délà deux
écrans donc au délà de penser que
l'usagé des tablettes ou des mobiles va
résoudre le problème des motivations ou
d'autres problèmes et que nous pensons à
engager les élèves pour être capable de
devenir des citoyens critiques écrêté
créatif da les usages du numérique mais
surtout pour résoudre des problèmes
ensemble
merci
[Applaudissements]